[Music]
[Applause]
there is nothing in the world quite like
Eva no eSports tournament no sporting
event no competition can compare to it
after all there's no event in the world
where everyone is a competitor or
everyone starts off on equal footing
where everyone it's a shock Evo is the
crucible where champions are made but
going oh and - isn't a curse it just
means you have someone to rule because
on championship Sunday the person who be
the person who made the person who beat
you is up there fighting to win the
story of Evo is one of the competitors
who show up every summer through their
memory it's the story of a community
fighting for their existence fighting
for the spirit of a community
eight hauled
[Applause]
EVO didn't begin as the massive 10,000
person juggernaut of a tournament that
it's known as today in the mid-90s the
North American fighting game community
was spread out across New York Northern
California Southern California and the
Midwest but players rarely competed
outside of their region's regional pride
was strong though arcades made for
intense close quarters competition and
the best player in the arcade was a
respected figure they were rulers of
their domain and they were always
looking to expand their kingdom to other
arcades and everyone wanted to take
their spot and you know if someone
showed up to your arcade that you had
never seen before you guys your crew had
to make sure that they beat them because
they were invaders and everything like
that and so there was just a lot of talk
but people didn't travel much for
fighting games back then there was no
professional scene no significant prize
pools occasionally one person went on
vacation and ended up in another cities
arcade and then returned home to either
talk trash or admit defeat that led to a
lot of inter-regional trash talk on
early internet message boards without
much of a way to settle the score and
there was a lot of well there's a lot of
[ __ ] talking that went on right so at
least not until battle by the bay
[Music]
1996 is battle by the bay was a chance
to prove which region reigns supreme
the energy was pretty strong in there
because it was really the first time
that something like this had ever
happened there was a couple of people
who flew out from Kuwait okay but that
was definitely very unique and very uh
you know surprising at the time
the tournament was a success and
inspired other multi regional
tournaments across the u.s. Evo
co-founders Tom cannon Tony cannon Joey
K R and Seth Killian didn't see the need
for another battle by the bay until 2000
when they hosted the B for Championships
held in Folsom near Sacramento b4 was
bigger in every way but it was still
held at a local arcade I just remember
there being a ton of people I remember
the place being hot as hell and I I
remember people just like chillin
outside like just talking it up and
stuff this time it wasn't the entire
scene that needed help it was the West
Coast players from the east had the East
Coast Championships as their Mecca and
while the West's massive player base
made for plenty of smaller tournaments
in the wake of d3 there wasn't anything
big enough to be a major then b5 hit the
next year and the tournament grew again
bringing Japanese competitors into the
fray for the first time everyone was
still in Sacramento which gave the
locals a chance to see players they
dreamed of playing against it was
actually pretty unreal like boss I'd
heard of boss I heard him for the first
time in alpha 3 and someone had
mentioned that he was coming to b5 and I
like immediately lost my [ __ ] the small
handful of Japanese players have showed
up dominated the games they competed in
which marked the beginning of the B
Series reputation as the tournament
series no other US tournament had
Japanese players in attendance and that
was a big deal I mean like I was saying
before it was a huge deal when we'd
heard that Japanese guys were coming to
to compete at p5 I was just like man
Japanese players play marvel to to like
I Nick like I knew they played
the the mainline Street Fighter games
but like I want to see these guys in
action for for Marvel to like and that
sort of brought like its own little
intrigue but the arcade scene that
birthed the battle by the bay
tournaments was dying fast by 2002
Southern Hills at Gulf land would close
and are kids all across North America
were going out of business the
competitive environment that created
fighting game communities all across the
world was going away in the States and
the crew behind b3 b4 and b5 wanted to
find a way to preserve it enter the
evolution Championship Series or Evo for
short Evo was meant to preserve the
spirit of the arcade even if the arcades
themselves were going away we're talking
about our kid culture and some people
think about like racing games or skeet
ball or something like that that's not
the part of our kid culture that we care
about we care about like the tournaments
that were happening all over the country
and that we really loved and wanted to
save and that's why we made Evo though
it wasn't always going to be called Evo
plenty of names were thrown around
including apex riot zone and fight con
Evo 2002 was held in a UCLA campus in
Pomona and the organizers rented arcade
machines from local arcades when they
realized they'd only have enough
machines for the tournament and none for
free play they had to get creative with
the event structure and we wanted to
turn the event not just into a
tournament but into a little bit of a
show right so that's where sunday comes
from okay let's run all the tournaments
until the top eight and then we'll run
the top eight the very best to the best
back to back to back to back on Sunday
and we'll be a show it'll the experience
or middle of it and they'll stick around
and that's where the idea of like top
eight comes from it's literally that by
Evo 2003 there were more than 300 people
in attendance it was easily the largest
fighting game tournament ever and the
sheer amount of attendees was getting
harder and harder to manage on top of
that the death of the arcade scene was
beginning to impact Evo in other ways
the more evil scaled up to have
more players participate in it the more
need you have to to make that
sustainable and because the game was
already on console it only made sense
the move that consoles was controversial
to say the least
if IVA was about preserving the spirit
of the arcade many assumed the hardware
would obviously follow the reaction to
the consoles which was not good I mean
it was almost universally reviled you
know like people were mad but the mid
2000s were something of a Dark Age for
plenty of Japanese fighting games
particularly Capcom fighters the
backbone of Evo in its early years and
you console ports if any were considered
arcade perfect for Capcom's games at
that point in time after third strike
there just really wasn't much happening
I think that a lot of people forget that
and a lot of people just don't realize
that that was that was a reality where
we really didn't we really didn't feel
like another another new thing was
coming out Evo's moved to consoles
wasn't smooth for the tournament as
Street Fighter 3 third strike didn't
have a console port that was even close
to tournament ready so Evo 2004 3s
tournament was run on arcade hardware
but the controversy was quickly swept
under the rug when the tournament
produced some of Evo's most memorable
moments
in what has now become one of the most
iconic eSports moments of all time
justin wong and Daigo Umehara two titans
in the scene faced off in the losers
finals of evo 2004 stirred strike
tournament Justin took a commanding lead
in the last round of the first game and
it seemed like he was gonna go up a game
in a key set with dye goes back to the
wall Justin bet that Daigo couldn't
parry every hit of chun-li's booyah who
sends super he bet that Daigo couldn't
execute 15 frame perfect inputs in a row
with all the pressure in the world on
him he was wrong
Daigo perfectly parried and punished
Justin super and won the round then the
game you know everyone kept talking
about how great he is and everything
like that but the tiger Perry was that
one moment where it happened and it
happened in front of a bunch of people
and it was the details evil moment 37
was everything Eva was supposed to be it
was a display of pure skill under
immense pressure with a crowd just
inches away from the players after that
Eva organizers and members of the
fighting game community realized that
things like Evo moment 37 which went
viral on a young YouTube could turn Evo
into an ambassador helping to grow the
fine game community
[Applause]
but Evo 2004 was also messy at times in
the Soul Calibur to Grand Finals RTD and
Mick played a pretty low quality match
and allegedly split the pot it was
obvious from anyone who plays fighting
games they were playing different
characters and they're playing with a
very subpar level the incident led Evo
to create their first collusion yet
another attempt to preserve the spirit
of true arcade era competition we should
look into that for next year because we
need to solve this problem
2005 presented another opportunity for
growth as the tournament moved from
California to Las Vegas thanks in part
to a partnership with major league
gaming but the partnership wasn't
exactly equal at the time Eva was bigger
than MLG in a way and in fact you know
they kind of tagged along with us you
know it was kind of a big deal Evo and
MLG split the venue 1/2 for Evo's
fighting games and the other half for
MLG halo and smash tournaments but Evo
brought way more players to the
tournament leaving them without any
space in their corner meanwhile MLG's
tournaments pulled in a quarter of what
Evo did it wasn't pretty
when halo was at Evo oh my god they had
a halo at Evo right in the middle of the
ballroom and after the halo tournament
one of the Canon brothers goes on the
megaphone and goes we would like to
congratulate team whatever was Team
Liquid or some [ __ ] right because
they're the winners of the halo
tournament and right when he said that
everyone in the whole room booth
yeah out of them and MLG has never
partnered with Evo since by 2006 evil is
big enough to get Capcom seal of
approval and even a toyota sponsorship
that led the tournament go on the road
with Evo East and Eva West it also led
them to include a racing game on the
roster for the first and last time when
Toyota became a sponsorship they wanted
at least one rate like something to do
with driving at Evo so they wanted
something and so they basically picked a
mario kart vs because it was gonna be an
easy way to add that into the schedule
but at Evo East the tournament hit a
snag Evo needed CRT TVs since more
modern TVs would introduce too much lag
but their supplier could only offer them
LCD and Plasma TVs a day before the
tournament started things got dicey
someone overheard the conversation about
the TVs and immediately went to the
shoryuken forums to say that the
tournament was ruined and that people
should stay home the Evo organizers
found a way putting 32 CRT TVs into a
truck in the middle of the night and
working to put on a good event or they
were going to until they realized the
truck was broken Tony is in the truck
with Gilbert gets on the horn Denis
warmer about halfway through and says to
me Tom there's a situation with the
truck
I'm like okay is everything all right
he's like well Gilbert tells me that the
clutch and so that means that if this
truck ever stops it's not gonna start
again until we fix it it's three M we're
on the highway we're 15 miles from home
right and the truck cannot stop right
it's like speed so we get like a few
miles down the road ahead of them and we
get to the toll road and set this
driving there's a truck behind us and it
can't stop there's like it's not out of
control it's a safe situation but the
truck behind us is not going to stop at
this toll
and the toll is like $2 he says here's
$20 this is for us and the truck behind
us right
it doesn't even wait for response gives
attended $20 rolls of them know and we
just like they rolled into the toll and
they slowed down as much as they could
and as they're approaching the toll
Gilbert and the attendants sort of had
this connection where their eyes locked
and get the attendant was like are you
the truck eaters like yes and the
tractor right and they're getting closer
and then like the gate raising right and
they go through right and you know 2001
marked the beginning of Justin Wong's
four-year Marvel vs. Capcom - Evo streak
that would go on to define marvel at Evo
for the rest of the decade
Justin won every Evo Marvel 2 tournament
between 2001 and 2004 after that he won
three more in oh six oh eight and 2010
MVC - his last year at the tournament in
that time though plenty of fighters
attempted to match Justin's incredible
run in 2005 duck doh the first evo
marvel - champion at b4 broke the streak
by taking first place with some
unorthodox spiral
in 2007 despite Justin's extraordinary
comeback against Yanks and losers yipeee
still managed to bring home the win in
2009 sanford kelly long considered to be
one of the East Coast's finest marvel
players brought down Justin in a grand
final to etch his own name into history
but Justin's performance at the final
Evo MVC 2 tournament in 2010 was
something of a sign history had spoken
and it said that Justin Wang was the
greatest Marvel 2 player to ever touch
the game but though Marvel 2 and a
variety of Street Fighter games with a
backbone of evil for years both games
were starting to feel a little stale by
the mid-2000s the hype from a small
community built around a dying genre and
out-of-date consoles just wasn't
sustaining Evo there were plenty of
attempts to bring people into the
tournament including adding new games
and rotating out old ones that's how the
story of super smash brothers melee at
Evo began melee first appeared at Evo in
2007 with Kent taking first place
[Applause]
winds evolution cementing his status as
the best melee player in the world at
the time but 2007 was also the last time
melee would appear at evo for the
foreseeable future
in 2008 melee was replaced by brawl
which the tournament organizers ran with
items on and a bizarre stage selection
process that led CPU a complete unknown
to defeat Ken in the grand finals the
brawl tournament soured plenty of smash
players on Evo and neither game
officially returned in 2009 2007 eight
games gave way to just six the next year
making it the smallest Evo lineup since
2002 in some people's eyes the shrinking
crowds and the smaller number of games
they were all pointing to one thing Evo
was dying and the arcade scene they were
striving to preserve would die along
with it in 2008 I still remember at one
point looking around the room and going
I know like almost everybody here like
I'm not seeing new faces and it just
felt like there was a peek at some point
and you know even the you know nbc-2 was
the strongest game for a while at that
point third strike was the strongest
game but it just didn't feel like it
didn't he just didn't have that same
pizzazz to it I don't know I can't
explain it but there was a small glimmer
of hope at Evo 2008 Capcom gave fans a
chance to play their first new fighting
game in years Street Fighter 4 Street
Fighter 4 had been announced months
before and had been available in
Japanese arcades but Evo 2008 was one of
the first times that the North American
FCC got their hands on the game that
could save their scene Street Fighter 4
was designed to be a return to form but
more importantly it was the first
numbered Street Fighter game since 3s in
1999 it was proof that Capcom still
cared about this community
that was born out of Street Fighter 2
all those years ago in fact Street
Fighter 4 was designed to play similarly
to Street Fighter 2 it removes some of
the more complicated mechanics
introduced from Street Fighter Alpha and
3 in favor of more straightforward play
meant to encourage lapsed fans back into
the fold
it worked
Eva went from a few hundred players in
2008 to a one thousand person Street
Fighter 4 bracket in 2009 it brought the
scene of back toe fights I remember
almost kind of sitting in that chair job
on the floor and just eyes wide open
like did this really just happen
it was the most insane experience that I
had ever had and probably only the
second time in my life the first time
being the Daigo parry moment that I down
and I was like this could be a thing as
soon as 2009 captain I was like no I
can't I can't go I have to stay I have
to ride this out in a perfect twist of
fate
Daigo played justin wong in the
first-ever Street Fighter 4 grand finals
calling back to their famous showdown
five years earlier it felt like it was
fate that brought them in the grand
finals and it felt like there was really
no chance maybe for Justin to win but
then he reset the bracket and I still
remember how crazy the audience was
going and this was the biggest the
audience crowd had ever been or not at
the hard time baby
Saigo that goes reactions is no good
that he can't make the Dragon Punch Time
dye goes win kicked off a new era for
Evo but perhaps more importantly he
kicked off a new era for the fgc the
quality of the match itself the
intensity of the set and the thrill of
being part of a 1,000 player bracket
kicked the tournament into high gear
thanks in part to Street Fighter 4 evil
has never looked back it's grown year
over a year to unbelievable pipes but
Street Fighter isn't the only reason Evo
has gotten some huge the tournaments
struggled through the hard time to come
out on the other side to a world where
one game didn't have to carry the whole
fgc Evo 2009 was the biggest ebo yet but
things were just getting started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right now this is moment
[Applause]